[Music]
between the snow-covered mountains deep
in kawan province in South Korea sits
one of the country's hottest spa crazes
and we mean literally hot day the moon's
Ultimo need to noon a warning on key
account of the video
[Music]
charcoal played an important role in
Korean culture its use dates back over
2600 years to heat homes cook food and
ward off bad energy Sir John one and his
father make charcoal from Oakland that
is unique to this region it's an arduous
process that starts and ends with kilns
or giant ovens chief Antonio Turkish
yogurt in Kumasi demanded a window at 20
victory returns headed to Casa de
camarones o-shizu commune de una cosa
dici corner in this harem each
embarrassing new moon toga heavily the
same vector occasional macho nacho and
hammering the open hatha yoga Maharaja
cookie the kilns function as a
traditional Korean sauna a treatment
that has been happening for hundreds of
years
customers pay a small fee to spend time
sweating out their toxins in the hot
rooms
Kim Johnson turkey channel know me under
Article II I'm so sorry Lucas had an
identity which attend your goal was of
to me to was equal the condom is a
silicon telling each evil evil attorney
at all my castle humanism honest money
he count those who simply known as for
this and a national attraction it will
stay so Jung Hwan has no plans of
slowing down the family business I wanna
meet ocean and the ocean each other
either hinge on this marina wasn't a
payment system some universality of
rhythm day Connie with the attentive you
got a you like some chicken and a good
Paramus you
[Music]
two words snail slime snail slime snails
love their own slime which is actually
their mucus it helps them to fight over
tea and move at a snail's pace Beckley
sure but humans ulta love snail slime
for its nutrient rich properties this
began thousands of years ago when
ancient Romans and Greeks gave snails
free reign to roam their faces no more
redness no more wrinkles for our
classical ancestors multi-person in
Mexico so far no man john lumic a beaver
problem for problema intestine alley
that is kinda of topic Simone but now
that you're here I think we should segue
dear introduction make a more smaller
sample a distract Obama
peruzzo cosmetic oh he's being modest
Simone is an inventor and a snail savior
before he invented his snail slime
extraction machine the only way to
collect mass quantities of snail slime
resulted in smells death not anymore
Paris Villa Park West imaginary or
suburban PA in peccato Nova initial
meant Emma Domino del paso new machina
Rio capo testa Estrella baba della Lou
Marquis in Oh Lucy Dell
we begin in the fields after munching
for 14 months snails are plucked washed
and brought to Simone's machine the
Mueller one sidebar snail secretes line
for three reasons to move out of stress
and for pleasure
simone calls his machine a spa for
snails because it pleasures them with a
secret spray to the point that they
secrete a lot of slime you know a silly
issue is traveling all the time
tranquila tranquila to a chain talk if
you don't talk metric I'll translate
that's as much as seven pounds of slime
from one batch after that the slime is
extracted dehydrated rehydrated and then
refined here for use in cosmetics here
it is being bottled and then it's
officer face yup I saw a body on fire
uniformity on a 14k l'Italia FINA or
just at the famosa
/ pizza pasta Maduro G Sarang k famosa
Perla bhava
D Katsuyama todo Carrasco best slime in
the world Simone if being bald is wrong
we don't want to be right
[Music]
this bottle this brand unique and busy
yet simple and standard you might have
seen it you might even use it but have
you ever read it
the dr. Bronner brand is the top-selling
organic soap company in North America
and if you look closely at the label
you'll see quotes from Jesus Einstein
George Washington you name it
you'll also read a lot about the moral
ABC the brainchild of dr. Emmanuel burr
honor the founder of dr. Bronner's magic
soaps born into a Jewish family in
Germany he immigrated to Milwaukee in
1929 and worked as a consultant for
various soap companies but his real
passion was philosophy he had a vision
for world peace and he called it moral
ABC its mission read in all we do let us
be generous fair and loving 2 spaceship
earth and all its inhabitants but were
all one or none all one basically he
wanted people to set aside their
religious and ethnic differences to find
common ground during World War two
Bronner began lecturing and spreading
his vision for peace and unity and he
started drawing crowds in 1947 during
one of his lecture tours Bronner was
arrested for giving a public speech
without a permit he wound up in a mental
institution he escaped and he made his
way to Southern California where he
declared himself a doctor rabbi and
alleged that he was Einstein's nephew it
was during this lecture tour that
Bronner began giving his family's soap
away he quickly realized people were
only coming for the free soap and
leaving before the lecture so Bronner
started printing his scriptures and
sticking them onto the bars and just
like that dr. Bronner's magic soap was
born
[Music]
yep and I saw darken Auto face - out
there a julep ordinance and seeing
sousou-sama tolerance a non-emotional
booyah
cumin seed also chant on my
haedongcheong scent Italia Italia our
Hodges your engine
yo prevailing de langue de hoc a
ten-cent open hood Dahlia or knife
therapy started 2,500 years ago in
ancient China as an alternative method
to traditional medicine no menses are
Taiwan's Eureka enforcing the ammo on ha
not even sure that I was young tolerance
if 800 order tell how sooner hash out
certain de needle son told him told yah
yah yah gasp Angelina Jo has been
practicing in teaching knife therapy for
14 years
whoa cool he's only Benelli alpha we've
and another thought you told at heart he
tells always Hajus with hope and how I
saw some sense the oh [ __ ] nah no single
solitary
tetany OD it with chains and Mahato I
knew it without sickle the whole tone i
sat down since Alice is your hometown
what you do but becoming one of the
18,000 qualified blade masters
takes real work where I'm Pat you go in
with the whole fall should see me no
miss Alma thought else's Sammy your
solution needs Altos onion Susan your
thoughts even I sure need Josh young the
knives are specially blunted and are
made based on a varied ratio of steel
and iron it is a customary practice to
hover the knives over burning sandalwood
and store them next to meteorites to
maintain the knives lightness and
efficiency many Korean recruits its
adultery so llamado ba-dump-bump a young
female foundation bien
okay so if it'll be a moon while the
idea of knives may seem unconventional
this tradition has seen a recent surge
in popularity across Taiwanese cities so
Taiwan I'm more the function Oh metal
ions youngsil Curzon put on the Alpha
giant icy ocean sheets Oh Monica due to
my father
no som Ohio young doubt million angio
bunions lighter Thalia Tashtego how the
issue truth-telling my assumptions a
fashion show you mean coriander seeds in
quick releases under yet similar - are
you chose an aura hands income
[Music]